totically fewer than Big O of root end queries in the worst case that's something that can be proved rigorously
and there are in fact multiple known proofs of this fact interestingly this was known even
before Grover's algorithm was discovered Grover's algorithm matched the already known lower bound on the number of
queries required from time to time people do come up with approaches that they believe are ASM
totically Superior to Grover's algorithm but there's always either a mistake or an assumption about the function f and
how it can be accessed or some other problematic issue that renders the claim incorrect if you're working properly
within the query model you can't beat Grover's algorithm for unstructured search second Grover's algorithm is
quite broadly applicable in the sense that the square root speed up that Grover's algorithm offers for the unstructured search problem can be
obtained in a variety of different settings for example sometimes it's possible to use Grover's algorithm on
top of another algorithm to get a quadratic Improvement beyond the performance of that algorithm Grover's algorithm is also
quite commonly used as a sub routine inside of other Quantum algorithms as just one simple example we
can use Grover's algorithm to get a quadratic advantage over classical algorithms for the minimum problem that I mentioned in
lesson five and finally the technique used in Grover's algorithm where we have two
Reflections that are composed and iterated to rotate a Quantum State Vector can be generalized in a pretty
Major Way an example is a technique known as amplitude amplification where a process
that generalizes Grover's algorithm can be applied to another quantum algorithm to essentially boost its success probability quadratically faster than
would be possible classically and that technique has broad applications in Quantum algorithms so it may be true that
Grover's algorithm isn't likely to lead to a practical Quantum Advantage anytime soon if ever but Grover's algorithm is
without a doubt a fundamentally important and broadly applicable Quantum algorithm and it's representative of a more General technique that has many
uses and that's it for this lesson and for this unit of the series which has been on Quantum
algorithms we discussed the query model and how we can connect it to a more standard model of computation along with
some other foundational Concepts concerning how we can measure computational cost we then covered phase estimation
and factoring and then finally Grover's algorithm as I've already suggested
there's a lot more to learn about Quantum algorithms but in this series we'll move on to a different topic in the next unit in particular we'll take a
look at the general formulation of quantum information where Quantum states are represented by matrices of a certain
sort known as density matrices as we'll see this formulation turns out to be very useful and indeed
essential for understanding some aspects of quantum information and it also happens to be quite beautiful from a
mathematical Viewpoint so I hope you'll join me for unit three and goodbye until
then